let's go next to joseph from tucson
joseph you're on the air
hey can you hear me yes i can
hi um i just had a question
where given the amount of just totally
unprecedented
events that we've seen over the past
couple of years yeah would it even be
very accurate to use assessments from
precedent when thinking about something
like the midterms in 2022
i think uh you you're making a good
point which is we make all of these
historical analyses uh typically after
you know it's sort of like in in
baseball where they say
you know um
the uh the orioles
in the seventh and eighth innings in day
games played after september
they tend to hit 400 with runners in
scoring position and it's like okay does
that historical analysis really tell us
anything actionable or substantive about
today and things are so wacky and
different right now we have a question
mark around like all those trumpists
that were activated by trump do they
care about the midterms are they going
to vote all of these different things so
i think it's fair to ask the question i
still do think that things are lining up
very much as they have historically
which is democrats took the white house
in 2020 it's not looking good for
democrats in the house of
representatives in 2022 i think a lot of
those historical
things are are
plausible in terms of the next election
cycle or two but you're right that we
always have to say well what's different
this time it might not all be the same
all right well very interesting thanks
for taking my call my pleasure uh great
to hear from you there uh there's joseph
from tucson
why don't we go next
to tobias
from germany tobias from germany you're
on here
thanks for having me my pleasure yes i
can
ah great
uh i have two questions
the first one is
mainly your opinion about freedom of
speech
because
when i look at the complete situation
i think that the media has big part of
the city of the
situation that you are in now
the lies on fox the lies from donald
um
it doesn't stop we thought it might
become better than biden wins and now
biden
is president for a year but nothing
changed
they doubled down
and
i don't see
anything
regarding healing of society
the
society gets split more and more and
do you see any way out of it
well unfortunately
if anybody thought joe biden being
president would reduce the lies in media
i expected the lies to go up and of
course they have and that's exactly the
way that that i expected it to go
but we don't you know here's the thing
we fundamentally don't have a system
that encourages or favors healing in the
way that you're talking about because it
requires number one putting partisanship
aside and i mean i'm partisan in saying
this but to heal we would need everybody
to say hey you know what
that trump experiment that was a
disaster we can never do that again we
were globally humiliated under trump we
we just we just can't but
like that's my partisan view and someone
else would say no no no david you're
you're just wrong about that that's not
what the healing is going to come from
so we can't even get agreement as to
what would cause the healing to take
place so there's a couple different
topics in there that you mentioned
they're all good but unfortunately
everything is exactly as i expected the
media lies have escalated with joe biden
the partisanship is certainly not
diminishing and even uncontroversial
things that joe biden wants to do like
an infrastructure plan
are now being seen by the right as these
radical communist ideas which of course
they're not
oh yes
yeah the problem is and i don't see any
way
out of it again so the next elections
might be the last
well i mean i don't that that's that's
very dark the next elections might be
the last but i share your concern about
growing authoritarianism for sure i'm
i'm right there with you tobias
okay
and
the other question if i get time for it
sure
it
might be a bit polemic but it's about
the line
between
being bad in your job being a bad
president not doing your duty and
treason
what i mean in specific is donald loves
to have people being upset that helps
him
and
he saw a chance in using corona to get
people upset
he politicizes corona
which leads to many dead people
instead of helping american people he is
killing them for his
yeah for his own good
and
isn't there somewhere a line that
it's going to treason
yeah there is a line i don't know what
the line is but i think it's important
to mention trump's handling of
coronavirus even if he thought it would
be good for him it wasn't good
leaders that handled the pandemic well
got re-elected trump lost and i believe
that if trump had handled the pandemic
well he would have won so the one area i
disagree with you is
i think trump may have calculated
pretending there's no pandemic is going
to help me it backfired and it might be
responsible for why he lost
yeah good but people are dead
i know
i know it doesn't help the people who
died no there's no question but but from
from the political argument you were
making uh tobias thank you great to hear
from you i really appreciate it
thank you all right there is tobias from
germany we're going to take a very quick
break if you're holding don't hang up
because we're going right back to the
phones in a moment